and HLA is one of those rare parts where
if you make the family tree of HLA
copies it doesn't go back a million
years or 1.2 or two million it goes back
40 million years so if you think of the
tree like it typically it'd be like a
million year tall Christmas tree this is
a 40 million year tall giant redwood
yeah 2k goes way back in time for HLA
that's a mystery in itself why does it
go back so deep in time where other
other parts of our chromosomes only go
back a million years boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake on we are on site in
Cambridge Massachusetts we are now going
to be talking about magical genes we
have dr. Nathaniel Pearson joining us on
the show hello hello sir
thank you so much for coming on Italy
pleasure very grateful for Alex Kate
Shen for introducing us we're gonna have
an epic yes yeah I was just gonna say
like some people are crucial hubs right
and connect with people in the world and
it's always a good thing
that's right hey Casey is such a crucial
hub we love you very much
Nathan is the founder of route which
reads your most vital DNA for free
helping you roam your family roots save
patients via better matches and spark
science that you love and you can check
out Nathan's links below his route deep
comm link below as well as his Twitter
profile and his LinkedIn profile links
below so magical genes really excited to
talk about this Nathan let's start
things off with your journey let's start
things off with your story you know you
have this profound story even right on
your website about you when you were six
teach us about this yeah and so I was
saying you know we're sitting on this
couch it feels Freudian and I and I will
tell you about about my mom and my mom
was one of the key sort of strands that
that wove together to become what root
is and and the idea that burned and
media to make happen and it's sort of
like your shirt so I love your shirt
this gets it the way that DNA really
sort of traces into the past and our
roots so my story what brought us here
to this couch today
is in part that as a young kid is a
young sort of proto scientist in the
world out exploring and then you know it
getting dirty and streams and bringing
home frogs and things like that one
really precious person in my life
encouraging that bringing out the young
scientist in me was my mom and in the
short time that I got to spend with her
she taught me a lot about the world and
really cultivated that spark of
curiosity that that would encourage
somebody to become a scientist sadly she
died when she was very young so she was
34 when she got a leukemia so basically
cells within her as in any cancer they a
mutant need they had genetic changes
that happen to them and that made them
differ from the other cells in her body
they started to grow out of control and
they overtook her body and they killed
her and she died in an early era of how
we were treating blood cancers when we
were just starting to think about how we
might actually use transplant somebody
else's cells to come to the rescue and
stop that mutiny today we're trying to
perfect that in the world and so the
mission of bone marrow transplant
was planted as a seed in might and my
understanding of the world very early on
by by her loss by the the flame that was
snuffed out that that was her that
memory lives on in me and I don't every
day I think of her like many of us who
have lost people think of that person
every day she still remains a big
influence on me but I think it was only
as an adult that I realized later how
that experience would entwine with my
broader understanding of genetics to
spark a new idea and aha moment about
how we could help there and the aha
moment is that the same genes that we
screen to see if somebody would be a
match for transplant to see if you could
be the person who helped save that
person who needs a transplant the aid of
blood you know
bone marrow or blood or a solid organ
same genes that we screen for many kinds
of
transplant match are called HLA five
genes on our sixth chromosome and those
genes are in many ways the most magical
and mysterious genes in our
constellation of 20,000 genes they are
the ones that help our bodies sense
what's going on with it
they I think of them as the hands of our
cells so they make these five proteins
so there's two copies one from mom and
one from dad and they make these hands
that each of our cells in our body use
to sense what other little protein
fragments are here in this body and
those could be proteins from a virus or
bacterium so they're they're classically
used to respond to to bugs to germs that
might infect us and decide help the body
decide what to do but they also might be
proteins from a tumor it might be
proteins from a fetus that's growing
within us and we need to know that we're
pregnant and in order to actually do you
know good things to help that fetus grow
they may be from other proteins that
ourselves are making they are they are
the hands that help our cells sense
what's going on within when they're
blind to otherwise and they're
exquisitely diverse so just like human
hands have fingerprints that are each
that are unique these hand genes these
five genes are they come in so many
varieties a stunning diversity that
we've kept around among our ancestors
that it's really hard to find somebody
who has exactly the same looking hands
as you and yet that becomes crucial for
transplant so this is where it becomes
magic to me and I think we talked a
little bit you know just just getting
know each other that transplant is a
form of real magic it's like it's as we
were saying it's um Harry Potter [ __ ]
mm-hmm so what you know that that my
bone marrow might save you is some kind
of magical stuff and and I might be the
only person who could save you so no one
else could step up and save you it's
almost like you know that scene in Star
Wars it's like help me Obi one you're
our only hope you may be the Obi one for
somebody out there in the world and you
may be the only person on the planet who
could save that person I couldn't
whoever you are if you were
couldn't only you could and likewise you
as the viewer might be the obi-wan the
only person on the planet who could save
somebody in need and that is something
that is just yeah it's it's almost
mind-boggling that that it's it's at
once medieval and sci-fi its medieval in
the sense that we still have to resort
to that to save up a cancer patient to
you know a marrow transplant but it's
sci-fi and that it actually works
sometimes so thinking about my own
experience with my mom and and how many
many families are grieving from the loss
of people like her who are big
influences for kids and and really
important parts of our lives I thought
how can we help more families find a
good well matched willing donor for
every patient who needs one
well one way we could do that is by
bringing those good donors those
volunteers insight from that good deed
about themselves they're healthy
volunteers they've stood up to the world
and said if I'm needed to give bone
marrow to give platelets to give you
know any as a transplant donor call me
if I'm needed in the one and that that
good deed should be honored and they
deserve to get their data back to learn
what it means for them to learn how to
weave it into their lives that's what we
found a route to do mm-hmm
and your analogy with the hands was
really powerful and I'm excited to
unpack that in more detail I want to
take us to the steps that you took
because you did
Stanford than he did University of
Chicago evolutionary genetics PhD take
us through those steps and then into
your first industry work a pre route
yeah okay yeah so um you know I so as a
kid you know when I was splashing around
in streams and stuff like that my mom
was encouraging me I was always asking
why questions I realize that looking
back like we asked different questions
in the world I think people who
engineers for example I think often
asked maybe how questions very
mechanistic for me it was why why does
not just the why is the sky blue but but
you know why this why that
and thinking about the history of things
it's the the causal chain that leads
from what was in the past to the present
how wise get us there that is a talking
to peers and evolutionary biology and
evolution genetics it's very common kind
of way of thinking in evolutionary
biology now why why our organisms why
are those critters that we love people
birds plants the life form that that you
know the life forms that that make the
planet such a wonderful place to live
why are they way there why are they the
way they are why are they so diverse why
are they in many cases suited well to
living in one way or one place not
another etc the questions that Darwin
traveled with and really foundationally
helped us understand well many of us had
followed in those footsteps and at
Stanford you know thinking about those
why questions I was interested in
languages to how they change and there
are parallels there with family trees
and when the trees of languages in their
past so that question of how do things
diversify and why that was sort of
running through my thinking and I didn't
really know where to put that thinking
that's an undergrad all the time like I
worked you know and with some really
lucky to work with some great peers and
in and gurus on both of those fronts and
biology and linguistics Joe Greenberg on
the languages side and luca
cavalli-sforza on biology on genetics
but eventually it crystallized tonight
and I started thinking about what Luca
had really pioneered which was
understanding human diversity mm-hmm how
did we get so splendidly diverse on the
planet in the way we look the ways that
we live our lives what history does that
reflect and how can we look at our DNA
and peer a little bit further back into
that darkness from it how does the DNA
lead from the leaves on the tree today
those are us back in time towards the
roots are our ancestors and really good
yeah oh ma and and once you you know
that was each of fruit on the we re too
early for fruit in
we responded ly diverse than that and
everybody's different and we and you
wanted to go back at the biological and
you know archaeological lineage of how
we actually got to where we're and they
entwine so the the one kind of evidence
from DNA supplements what we can learn
from from digging through old you know
trash heaps yeah old cultures had or or
now recovering the DNA from from soil
and trying to figure out what organism
slept there and one of people were
eating at the time or things like that
so that question came to captivate me
human diversity and I was really lucky
at 25 to get to go on a long trip this
just before starting grad school I went
to on a long trip across Southwest and
Central Asia
so we basically drove from London to the
Chinese border and back Wow over five
months this was led by a guy named
Spencer Wells whom many of you may know
who's a you know prominent population
geneticist and Spencer that's how he saw
fit to let me ride a long shotgun and
and and help sort of you know speak
languages to people along the way and
and process blood samples and things
like that and start to document human
genetic diversity in a part of the world
that had been really not yet well
studied yet and there remain other parts
of the world especially outside of
Europe that have just not been
documented well we've been very
Eurocentric and our biases and and this
was an early effort to start to branch
out beyond that a little bit and we we
learned a little bit scientifically from
that trip from collecting blood from
roughly a thousand people across that
swath of the planet
I learned a hell of a lot for life I
mean it was a mind-warping experience to
suddenly be exposed to the cultural
diversity that you can get to with a
jeep driving from London to China and
the realization that this ocean of land
has been open to people moving across it
for many not just millennia but dozens
of millennia like the human rootedness
of us in different parts of the planet
started to dawn on me and it just was a
real like
mind opening experience to go on as a
lucky young scientist then coming back
that's how you that's real population
genetic it's out there in the world and
you going and doing it hands-on for five
months and and you said you sampled
blood even yeah and also we're able to
get behind the eyes of so many different
humans and culture and talk with them
and write and about their experiences in
their lives and and you know admittedly
often with halting you know lingua
franca that we could speak maybe I spoke
a little bit of Rutan Russian truth or a
little bit of Persian and they spoke
maybe a little bit of a tingling or
Weger and you and you make do and you
bet you explain to each other you know
they would take a loop down from the
wall and play it and and and there are
these human interactions that that
transcend the language barriers yeah and
that are just as important as anything
you're gonna learn later in the lab from
that person's DNA and it also teaches
you what you can't yet learn what you
can't yet explained to them it teaches
you about some of the ethical challenges
that we face and in sort of you know
swooping into a village and thank you
very much sampling DNA from people and
then how do you get back the insights to
those people how do you make sure that
they understand well a why you're
interested in their DNA that it's about
human history in this case and not about
helping them solve a family health issue
and not about them maybe worrying about
you know contamination in the soil you
know from some from like making sure
they understand you're not there because
there's been an industrial accident or
something like that
ethics looms large and a lot of those
questions are really challenging and and
there were suddenly in your face in the
field so yes feel biology it's a great
liberal education in itself yes coming
back from that
it was lucky to go to a grad school in
place the University of Chicago where
suddenly you're in this very crystalline
time in in our field so evolutionary
genetics in the 90s and the early 2000s
was a very mathematically rigorous of
the we didn't have DNA sequencers that
can read a lot of the
yet each each letter we read was still
pretty expensive so we had to learn as
much as we could from the few that we
could read and that meant thinking
really carefully about how to understand
the mathematics of what you learned yeah
that was a good grounding in in
theoretical population genetics which
teaches you a lot about all the things
you can guess about the past from just
looking at the way DNA varies today and
that's when the that's when the first
inkling hit me of how much we can learn
from this part of our genomes that we
focus on in route which is called HLA
and so these HLA genes they think of a
family tree and we've all got family
trees for our own families where you
know you go back in time and you and
your branch to mom and dad and then
their mom mom and mom's mom and mom's
dad and and all the ancestors going back
and eventually they entangled because
some of them had the same ancestor so
it's a complex web you want to learn
about that just like we have family
trees the copies of our chromosomes also
have family trees and so you could take
your two copies of you know the sixth
chromosome or the first chromosome and
my two and your two and everybody in the
planets copies and you could make a
family tree and of how those copies go
back to their own ancestors one
generation back two generations back and
then back into the sort of mists of deep
time and we've unfortunately have not
been able to do a good job at
documenting the six million years of
ancestral evolution you're talking about
since we since our ancestors diverged
from other great ancestors so we we've
started to patch it together and we're
starting to get some amazing insights on
on the sort of it's a lot of a
soap-opera insights about who who took -
back in time you know the nice events
living in Sunderland and you know the in
Southeast Asia where they're Islands now
who you know may have intermingled with
with so-called modern humans who were
suddenly traipsing through and they got
it on and and the story is the same
everywhere when people people get a
chance they get it all
and and we are the the wonderfully
varied and wonderfully swirled together
you know it's the the Dairy Queen swirls
of that today the the 31 flavors and
many more of humanity are the result of
all that mixing so we can start to
figure it out looking at our DNA now and
we have a tendency to mix oh we do that
we were you notice and then all of us
would probably notice that's it's a good
thing so the cool thing with HLA though
so if you make this family tree of
copies of a human chromosome typically
they go back to one copy that the the
last ancestor of all of those copies
that are in us today all all 14 billion
or so copies of chromosome one at a
given position would go back to one
ancestral copy that ancestral copy was
in somebody about typically a million
years back so all of them go back to one
copy and that was in an ancestor of ours
about a million years ago two different
ancestor as you move along the
chromosome for a complex little process
called recombination where chromosomes
get they get sort of cut and pasted back
together and a quilt over time so this
this letter could be one ancestor a
million years ago who lived in in South
East Africa another another the letter
over might go back to a different
ancestor who lived 1.2 million years ago
a thousand kilometres away they never
knew each other different ancestors but
more or less same part of the world
southern or Eastern Africa and more or
less than million years ago okay for
some parts of our genome the picture
looks totally different
and HLA is one of those rare parts where
if you make the family tree of HLA
copies it doesn't go back a million
years or 1.2 or 2 million
it goes back 40 million years so if you
think of the tree like it typically it'd
be like a million year tall Christmas
tree this is a 40 million year tall
giant redwood yeah okay it goes way back
in time for HLA that's a mystery in
itself why does he go back so deep in
time where other other parts of our
chromosomes only go back a million years
so HLA is found in the 6th 6th come from
our chromosomes have long and short arms
they've got a long arm and they've got a
shorter arm like this and HLA is on the
short arm of the sixth chromosome and
it's about a stretch of DNA that's about
4 million letters that have that much
longer chromosome Wow and it's all there
together there's a bunch of little genes
in there yeah there's there's five
so-called classical genes in there and
those are the ones that make the five
fingers that our fingers that our hand
ourselves use to sort of sense the
proteins in that that part was so
profound to so the so so so HLA genes
give cells the ability to sense what's
going on in the body and make those
adjustments that are needed yeah and
this everything from like digestion like
digests absolutely so and we often
caricature them we think of them as the
epicenter of the immune system so we
think that I mean so you know they help
respond to bacteria viruses protozoa
other germs that we eat or that you know
we get from somebody sneezing or or
however or from sex and and they help
our bodies respond to those and know
that there's an alarm set off the alarm
call the immune system call the t-cells
in and they come and they then it's it's
almost like the classic Victorian murder
mystery what they're doing is these
hands are taking a little scrap of
protein from that germ like the
bloodhound with the handkerchief from
the killer
and they're saying here immune system
smell smell this your bloodhound smell
what does this little protein smell like
now go get him go get him anything that
any cell that has this little fragment
of a protein kill the cell that's the
classic way we think what a chilli is
like prompting the immune system to
rally well and kill off an invader it's
much more nuanced than that and you
asked about congestion so so we teach us
what HLA stands yeah sure
so it's human leukocyte antigen so so
human-like people like us leukocyte is
white some white blood cells antigen so
the so antibodies are those they're
these proteins that swarm in on unlike a
germ and help the immune system say hey
over here we got you know we're holding
it down for you come come and come you
know take care of this one
so antigens are what prompt those
antibodies to come and swarm they were
there what fit so human leukocyte
antigen and so it's sort of the helping
make the helping hold out the little
fragment of protein so that the immune
system can respond to it in broader
other mammals it's called the major
histocompatibility complex MHC same
genes so you're just different fancy
jargon same genes just okay so those
genes they're really important - how can
I make a potential rookie fresh
perspective on the HLA s is it is it
could be that the reason why it is a
redwood compared to just a Christmas
trees because of its use case in the
body it's such a so valid value in the
body so if you're you have a hunch a
great hunch and that hunch is very well
intuited we think and it's not proven
but we think that one reason at least
why HLA remains so diverse it basically
we've kept around diversity in our
population of ancestors since 40 million
years ago we think that just for your as
your question guesses that's because
it's been useful to keep that diversity
around and the simple way of thinking
about that why would it be useful to
have diversity an immune response system
so to make sure that our kids can
respond
to a diverse array of potential threats
I mean you know terms so you want you
want to have a healthy broody kids you
want to make sure that they can respond
to this virus that bacterium that
protozoan until you we think that our
ancestors have may be chosen mates to
have HLA that differs from their own to
have kids that are more diverse with an
HLA then they would be at random yeah
okay so it's almost the opposite like
you know in transplant we're trying to
find that rare match for somebody who
needs you need to find that that OB one
who happens to match exactly your HLA
with with mate choice we think it's
almost the opposite we think people may
have been trying to find somebody who
smelled a little different and they
didn't know why it's not like there's
nobody reading HLA out but just felt
sexier there was more of that spark
there and we think that that might have
to do with HLA so how does that happen
we don't know yet you don't even know if
it happens something I'm curious about
it but you could one way it could happen
we know about micro biomes now yeah so
micro biomes are the you know the the
mix of germs that lives in say our gut
or in our mouth well there's a there are
micro biomes include skin micro biomes
so what grows you know our armpits or on
our skin generally and the different mix
of germs on there is going to smell
different so it could be that folks are
you know you're used to your own smell
from that mix of microbes that are
living on your skin and that's in part
because of which a which germs your HLA
prompts your body to rally against and
which ones that kind of welcomes it's a
distinctive mix to you and in finding
somebody who smells sexy to you it may
be you're just looking for somebody who
smells a little bit different and that's
one that's one idea of how it is not
only fascinating and it's cool how HLA
both gives you the the rare match as
well as the desire for swirl yeah that's
world up and there's a lot of complexity
and so it it's not i've caricatured it
here like in a just so story way in a
really simple fable and reality is a lot
Messier and we solve a lot to learn but
let me get back to your question about
about digestion because that's a great
one okay right so every so
hla epicenter of our immune system along
with some other genes that help as well
like interleukins and in these kinds
between but also crucial in just about
every big autoimmune disease type one
diabetes lupus rheumatoid arthritis all
the biggies there celiac disease so how
some people can t eat wheat without
getting sick and I'm talking about real
celiac not where people are just sort of
avoiding gluten because it's trendy not
to caricature that but but where people
their hair falls out you know they get
severe symptoms if they have wheat that
is prompted mainly through HLA so if I
know that you have true celiac disease I
know that you very likely like 95%
chance have one of two different HLA
types that predispose to that that
disease
likewise everything we know about peanut
allergy so where the body's again
responding to a little protein fragment
of what we eat traces first to HLA and a
couple other genes much of our bodies
sort of like blind figuring out of what
what's here has to do with that HLA
sensing the protein be it a peanut
protein a wheat protein a viral protein
or in the cases the good stuff again
when we're pregnant when we need to make
sure that that newly conceived fetus
implants well in the you know in in and
and gets a good placenta to supply it
with nutrients over the course of
pregnancy that process is mediated in
part through HLA recognizing a-ha
there's some somebody different in the
cell and in the blood here I'm sensing
proteins that don't look like they're
from us body looks like from another
body
and so HLA figures crucially in
pregnancy health so a lot of what we
want to do with with root is start with
helping people who volunteer as a
transplant volunteer and say I'm
available if I'm ever needed very few
people will ever get the call to give
marrow
so maybe one in 400 will ever get to
give marrow the other 399 all want to do
something good in the world with their
cells their data they want to help the
health of others and humanity there is
so much science that is mediated
centrally through HLA first
understanding peanut allergy
understanding who gets type 1 diabetes
or doesn't understanding who gets lupus
understanding who gets pregnancy
complications how people respond to I
mean there are all the drugs all of that
science goes right through HLA people
deserve to get their data back their HLA
data for free to take charge of it and
own it so that they know it's that they
decide how it's used in the world not
somebody else
and ideally they can get some stake in
how it's used so if there if if there's
a discovery made I would like to see
Reuters get credited for that discovery
yeah intellectually and ideally also
when there's when there's lucre when
there's profit made on that discovery
I'd like to see people you see part of
that profit they've contributed to it
and they deserve that so we'd like to do
this in like a public benefit
corporation kind of way that we can make
happen for those 399 people who never
get to get bone marrow but would still
love to help out with with science
there's so much starts with HOA and I
say that it's funny I think really
broadly about our genomes I think about
all six you know almost 7 billion
letters in your genome and mine and how
all of those can matter but I would go
to science content conference after
conference year after year and HLA
always photobombs the picture when
there's a big study of what we're in our
genomes varies with who gets sick and
who doesn't with this particular disease
and again it could be lupus it could be
narcolepsy it could be MS multiple
sclerosis it could be you know any
number it could be ankylosing
spondylitis or who people how do people
get alopecia when their hair falls out
all kinds of different health questions
HLA would always be there that
a huge peak on chromosome 6p on the
short arm and the the researcher will
always say well of course we saw this a
strong association with HLA but let's
look at the next slide where we can see
a peak a different peak that we can
understand better because that diversity
of HLA I want out on it because it's so
deep it goes so far back in time but it
really scares off a lot of other reasons
research and it's time to dig in and
time to say hey with with crowd data
with with your help with all of our help
pooling our data we can actually advance
science we can join your story is what I
think many people can relate to because
we usually find our greatest treasures
on the other side of our greatest
traumas and our thought of our greatest
fears and you experienced what you did
with your mother potentially so that you
could be the this biology and and
anthropology pioneer and that that HLA
genes pioneer this and this maybe and
it's a huge potentially moment of AHA
for other young people that are like you
know why are these walls up well maybe
the walls are up to challenge you to get
through the walls so that you can find
your greatest treasures on the other
side of the walls and that's where we
find the most meaning in our life but
then you take this all the way to if I
you know you've been doing route now for
three years and so when someone signs up
for route they're they're usually
getting is saliva is that the yeah so so
so HLA typing is typically done today
through spit yeah and so you give a spit
kit either it at a marrow drive where we
can we're gonna have ways to arrange to
get a kit to you and then that DNA gets
typed and we want to bring people to
back their HLA type and I should mention
also we we will likely branch out soon
to blood donation as well because we can
do something very helpful very similar
in how
for there and when you look at blood
donation there are some other low site
that low site jargon sorry other other
genes in our genome that really matter
for for blood donation as well for blood
match and we know of course you know [ __ ]
so the [ __ ] blood group a similarly
mysterious one where the diversity goes
way back in time wait and by the way
forty million years back way predates
the divergence of people in chimpanzee
ancestors right I've all right so we're
talking about diversity that's actually
shared with other great apes it is
remarkable and so we donation will bring
people back insights about [ __ ] any other
other parts of our genomes that are
screened for that process as well and
HLA matters a lot in platelet donation
so that particularly the little little
thin layer in the when blood gets spun
down there's a thin layer of platelets
which would help stop the bleeding
basically when somebody's got car
accident or they need chronic
transfusions because they have a blood
cancer and they're in there bleeding a
lot the platelet donation works much
better when it's HLA matched the same
way that marrow would be so HLA matters
in the blood world too and and we love
the idea of being able to help encourage
that here in Boston and in most cities
today on a Saturday a typical day
roughly two-thirds of blood banks have
less than three days worth of blood on
hand so that's dire right so it's a
constant a constant search for new blood
and platelets in particular go bad after
you know a week then we kept at room
temperature so we really hope that we
can help there as well I loved your
insight and that often traumas it's
trite but you could think of them as you
know the stuff that doesn't kill us that
makes us stronger the you know the the
grit in the oyster that that then the
pearl forms around sometimes these these
tough the tough experiences that
everybody goes through in life and
they're gonna vary from person to person
you've got yours you've got yours I know
some of mine
those do indeed prompt the deep thinking
the soul-searching yeah they
gut-wrenching soul-searching yeah
that can go on for years until it it
marries itself to an idea aptitude
acumen what else you've got and other
lucky resources you have in her family
in your world - then say AHA this is a
direction that that I could go in to
help better things happen in the world
and absolutely I so many people when we
talk and you put you may experience this
as well with folks you talk with and
their career paths in health care
especially many of my colleagues
likewise were drawn to be scientists or
caregivers or funders of health care and
research because of personal experiences
with loss because they lost a sibling
yeah they lost a spouse they many kinds
of loss and those make one acutely feel
they hurt and they make one think and
understand her makes you want to take a
burden on your back to go and research
and learn and and be a part of
contributing to the edge of that field
yeah that you can help other people
going through the experience
it's an you know a couple thoughts here
one of the thoughts is when you when
you're explaining to people that go
through deep you get you get this live a
kit you ship it back in and then you you
you actually provide you gave a couple
examples here one of the examples as you
give them an understanding of their
roots an understanding of their ancestry
you also mentioned that they're
contributing to the spark of science of
science yeah so there's two ways
actually there's three ways that we we
bring people there
three views on your on your data because
it can be wonky stuff right it's a bunch
of letters in your in your DNA what does
it mean well think of them almost as
past you could think of them roughly as
kinds of past present future so looking
back into the past what does DNA tell
you what does your DNA say about the
past the human past and the past in
particular in your ancestry so you
mentioned we have our interfaces built
around the globe and we want people to
feel that connection to the planet we
live on
and to other people on it and so where
on the planet does your DNA your HLA in
particular tie you to other leaves on
that tree on that family tree of HLA
where you have cousins you haven't met
yet who may be ticklish ly far apart
from you on the on the planet in ways
you never would have foreseen a real
surprise on the other side of the planet
and people who who don't necessarily
look anything like you in the mirror
but are nonetheless your close cousins
in HLA and we should emphasize that HLA
because it goes so deep can take you way
it can take you way across the planet
other parts of our genome tell you about
other ancestors that you may share with
people
so part of our interface is that is
tying in to that that really heartfelt
need to connect you and I are cousins
right we don't know exactly where in our
genome there's the evidence of that most
clearly like most recently could be a
Chile it could be elsewhere but we're
cousins and everybody every pair of
people is we want to bring people to
closer together with that understanding
of where their cousins are on the planet
today and in turn to be able to
contemplate what does that mean for the
past where did people come from in the
past who migrated to those different
parts the planets so that's what the
globe interface is about that's that's
you know looking back in history to the
roots right of people of your you know
your own roots in Alex Haley's memorable
phrase right
on the science side that's looking ahead
to the future right and there's a
wide-open set of questions oh really a
rainbow of questions that hla sort of
shines light onto it is the first thing
we know genetically about you know
everything we've said from lupus to you
know
parity like to preeclampsia preterm
birth to to narcolepsy and peanut
allergy and celiac disease and and all
these other amazing amazingly diverse
frontiers of health knowledge
nonetheless means we still know too
little about each of those so what we
want and root is to be able to let
people decide what kinds of research
turns them on and if a question so you
know let's say you know a question like
you know why did why do some germs make
some people sick and not other people we
want people they look like a dating app
like swipe right hey that's a cool
question or boring take me the next
question what what else you got and
decide what kinds of questions they
would like to put their data toward and
they don't have to decide to keep their
data fully to themselves they don't they
don't you don't have to share your data
and route at all it belongs to you you
decide how and if it gets shared at all
and again we want you to benefit and
know how that's that's happening and
it's in a national registry in the case
that somebody does in the one in 400
case you need a marrow that's where it
starts so when you join the National
Marrow Donor Program or another national
registry you're agreeing to take that
phone call if you're needed yes if you
need it and then you're also sparking
all this additional sign
rights but this is open frontiers of
science and why I say that it's like
your choice with these valves for data
control right so let me give it exactly
let's take the peanut allergy example so
most of what we know genetically about
about who gets peanut allergy traces to
HLA and a couple of other genes but we
know far too little yet to say whether a
given toddler is going to get you know
anaphylactic shock if she eats peanuts
we can't predict yet that we can't
predict from your DNA if you're going to
be alert
peanuts that's that's a sobering
realization that we you know don't
expect your DNA to tell you too much yet
it's not about it's it's almost like
Kennedy you know like ask not what your
DNA can do for you ask what our DNA
together could do for a future
generation yeah yeah that's good so to
help understand fill for a future
toddler to make her genome more
informative of whether or not her
parents should feed her peanuts at you
know before weaning after weaning any at
any point in her life we need to do more
research and pull together what we know
and what we don't know and follow it
over you know at the speed of life how
allergies unfold not light but life and
in doing so like drive research that
makes it clearer in five years or in 10
years who is going to be allergic to
peanuts from birth and maybe maybe
intervene then there may be emerging
ways to intervene and make sure somebody
doesn't get sick if they take if they're
given peanuts at a restaurant
excellently beyond just having an EpiPen
but but to sort of like more
systemically kind of do that and so to
let people flex their data like muscles
on behalf of the science questions that
excite them that's that that's the the
forward-looking part of what we wants to
do right and then there's the then
there's the now what is my DNA say about
me now and that's that's the the health
report
so root will we we want to deliver to
people a very narrow and well grounded
health report that does not try to
stretch what we can say so one of the
problems we've seen in consumer genetics
is that because everybody's striving for
venture capital funding and people want
to you know get get a big lead here and
there they're always kind of pushing the
envelope of what what the data mean and
kind of toeing the boundary of [ __ ]
and we don't want that we want to
inoculate people against [ __ ] we
want people understand what their data
don't yet say okay so what what can HLA
say about your health today there's a
very narrow set of drug response outlook
findings so we know
the FDA has already validated that we
know that people with particular HLA
types are more much more at risk of say
severe liver damage if they take a tumor
drug called lapatinib or of a full-body
blistering a very horrific skin
blistering that happens called
stevens-johnson syndrome if they take a
couple of nerve disease drugs safer
epilepsies or other other nerve diseases
we know that HLA strongly predicts those
risks and the FDA has validated those
insights scientifically and those are
the kind of insights that we would feel
comfortable bringing back to people
personally about their own health
outlook today yeah that's a narrow
sliver so just like you know in avakov
navicomp has this beautiful passage i
think you can speak memory talking about
life as this brief brief like flash of
light total between two dark voids yeah
that's the narrow now right the moment
we're living in and there's something to
say from HLA and from other parts of our
genomes for people there but we want
them to know how limited that is but we
also want to cast that light into the to
to other directions so looking back into
the past yeah - what does it tell where
does it shine light on our common roots
I know particular part of the planet way
back in a million years back ten million
years back even 40 million years back
when I go to the zoo I can know if I
know the HLA type of my HOA type and I
know the group you know a particular
western lowland gorillas a MHC type and
a different one I know which of those
gorillas is my closest cousin not just
that they're cut every we all know now
that other great apes are our cousins
but I know that one of them is actually
a closer cousin to me then you are I'm
closer in HLA maybe to that gorilla than
to you and your and that gorilla is
closer to me than to its own sibling or
cage mate
that's remarkable depth of understanding
of the past and and evolution yes in
their future and then looking to the
future again how can we take our data
pull it together as we will with
autonomy that's right
safeguarding our rights and our privacy
and making sure that we have a stake in
outcomes but how can we come together
and make a baby's genome much more
informative for her his health outlook
10 years hence that's the vision that
everybody aspires to in our field and
everybody's kind of on board and there
are different boats yeah but we root
wants to be one of those boats and we
want to be the one that focuses on these
five genes that have really gone unsung
yeah outside of the transplant world but
that means so much and I'll add one more
thing here which is that and I'm a
member of 23 me in of ancestry DNA and I
do every you know I wear a Fitbit I I'm
an inveterate data data geek right maybe
you are too and all that is I love it
but 23 Me's tests can't they get only a
very blurry look at HLA HLA is far too
diverse it's like they don't have a
light powerful enough to shine 40
million years back into the past their
light shines about a million years back
but as their us multiple right they're
looking at they're looking at sites of
scattered or salteena Ross yeah that's
really well put so they're it's like
Christmas tree lights there they're like
every you know there's like a million
sites strung out all our chromosomes at
each of those in 23 me there are two
spellings typically and each copy of a
chromosome has one of those two
spellings and both of them are common
well common spellings are informative
they help us distinguish where you know
what the copies look like in different
continents and where they where yours
might have come from
but the harmful stuff and the really
rare functionally distinctive stuff and
intriguing stuff in our genomes never
gets common
it remains the rare variation the rare
letters that are that are hardly ever
seen but are sometimes vitally needed
sometimes they're harmful but sometimes
they're vitally needed to find a match
an HLA is one of those spots where
there's just the variation of spelling
of DNA there is way too intricate and
rare too to guess from the kind of like
Wheel of Fortune letters that the
23andme opens they open like every 10th
letter and you have to guess what the
phrase is
if the phrase is a really rare piece of
text you can't guess it
and that's HLA HLA is this really rare
little gem of a poem about you in very
very distinctive words and somewhere out
there there might be somebody with like
a matching locket that has the rest of
that the same poem written in it and
that may be also true not only for the
donor on the match side but also for
your swirl for your for your mating
absolutely and and again right so you've
got two copies of that poem and your and
you know think of them as love sonnets
in this case but you're looking for
somebody out there who has a difference
difference on it and you can you can
swirl yours together and you know it's
like oh it's alright there's we can go
crazy or with analogies
it's like a mash-up it's like you're
making this great mashup musically
between two really great two really
great songs that you never thought might
go together or like you know that you
know Jane Austen zombies you know that's
a chole it's like it's a it's Jane
Austen meets the zombies and it and you
mash them up and you get something
utterly new utterly textually
distinctive in DNA text and riveting
right and and and so all of this is to
say 23 means great root is bringing you
a different look at much deeper look at
a part of your genome that you can't get
there 23 that redwood tree yeah 40
million years so to both if you've got
if you can afford the nine bucks yeah if
you can afford 99
pay 23 me and get that broad look of the
Christmas trees across your chromosomes
if you would be willing to help other
people yeah with your cells someday join
route get that insight back for free
because we want to be different that way
too we will you're doing something
really good has a potential transmit
volunteer a blood donor or whatever it
might be you deserve that for free you
should not have to pay for that so do it
do route to get both of those insights
back and then decide in the world a how
you want to have fun with your data and
understand what it meant about your
family past and your your cousin's today
and then think about what kinds of
science questions what I like to help
answer yeah this is such a good
conversation if anything I've had such a
blast talking to you about the magical
genes that are HLA I love that you let
people like you let them get out and
what obsesses them and hopefully that
spark of what obsesses somebody else
that's been driving them for a long time
hopefully it catches ya in a few brains
that are watching you know when I watch
shows like yours I love that your your
you're stretching eclectic minds to ever
new topics that might excite them that
might clue them in to something that not
just interest them but that they could
do something about in the world is it
might be start their own startup you
know a based an idea that the tragic
loss brought them in their own
experience it might also be thinking
about the science questions that excite
them aha
you know the ones that you know why why
do some germs make some people say well
how could I help answer that well now
you know you know and and there's lots
of ways that that you're inspiring
people to do good things I love that
thank you so much they came up again
yeah after the sistine fist bump began
the sistine I love it
all right two quick questions on the way
out that we like asking our guests on
the show are we in a simulation
I'm gonna diss simulate on that
my hunch is yes and no my hunch is that
the simulation that were at my hunches
say that that experience is real that
that the the squishy pockets of a
universe and in your brain and mind that
that are you know a little squishy
pockets of the cosmos there they are
synthesizing information that's coming
in from around them streaming together
and swirling around and they are then
conjuring up this consciousness right
this is the great hard problem right now
after the consciousness problem so the
universe is self-aware and it's
self-aware through at least one I'm
gonna grant you this it's your cell ops
ISM at least one and two simulations why
I feel like they're simulations is well
of course everything is distort and of
course I'm only seeing colors you know
artificially projected onto my visual
field that represent part a little
sliver of the the the spectrum of
photons of frequencies that I could be
seeing so I've distilled down my Squishy
bit of the cosmos it's distilled down
all that information to a very very
simplistic representation of it that to
me feels like a model maybe a simulation
in some ways plus I know that I can
probably not by freewill I'm gonna say
but but my but my little squishy pocket
does imagine and drift off and daydream
and those are simulations so my answer
is yes number one and then the other
question is what is the most beautiful
thing in the world
I don't know I know the I know the one
singular breathtaking Beauty epiphany
that sticks in my craw and I think about
it is I'm not sure if it was Michael
light or another astronaut but the the
Big Blue Marble image oh the pale blue
dot Carlson not but that was later that
was really cool too but this is earlier
this is the first blue marble then lubu
marble was when one of the lunar
astronauts they were they were orbiting
the moon and they did one orbiter on the
you know the dark side and came up over
again and and saw earth the overview
effect and they saw Earth rising yeah
and amid this you know stark sterile
moon scape yeah suddenly there is this
this marble Baskin Robbins swirl rising
up in front of him and the reason that
came to mind when you ask the question
is like you said what the most beautiful
thing well it's really hard to pick one
little fragment of Earth which is where
my experience in yours is confined to
and say that's the most beautiful like
the face of somebody you know the face
of love or or you know Shakespeare
sonnet or whatever it might be or a
piece of music there's so much beauties
we're seething in it but all of it is
confined to this to this big blue marble
yeah so I I love that image and it I
don't know just stuck with me and memory
agreed yeah the overview effect is one
of the most profound ways for us to gain
stewardship for Earth and you know the
one the oneness that we need to prosper
most effectively this was such a stellar
interview I'm very excited for when you
come back to San Francisco or for when
we come back to Cambridge we got to talk
more HLA genes we got to talk more about
all this this was just so enlightening
there's a lot that we could go in
the roots the leaves are so many places
that will rock that will rock and let's
say I hope when that happens that more
folks will have joined root and there'll
be more to talk about from and with each
other as part of the conversation that
you're just stoking yes through through
the show here yes boom or boom I love it
I love it everyone thank you so so much
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below let us know what
you're thinking about that but so go and
share these conversations about HLA
genes go start talking to other people
in your communities and your family
online your coworkers let's get the
conversations roll and also check out
the link in the bio to root deep root
deep calm go and check them out and go
in go and maybe potentially enter in
enter in and see what this process is
like going try 23andme to see what the
process like start wearing fitbit's get
these quantified self or rings get your
get yourself moving in the quantified
self world in this feel that out see how
it is and also follow Nathan below as
well as Twitter also his LinkedIn
profile go and follow him and also
support the artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in around the world
support organizations around the world
that are making great impact simulations
links are below help us grow and scale
help us continue being able to come on
site like places like Cambridge to
conduct these interviews and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world thank you so much
for tuning in we love you very much
we'll see you soon peace that rocked
amen brother
really well put thank you yeah so you
that that's really eloquent I love men
what do you say manifest your manifest
surge your dreams our destiny into the
world yeah yeah just make it real yeah
turning real manifest it yeah